five hold on let's just wait let's just
wait a bit see no worries how long it
takes to to get us live I think let's
see here I'm gonna pull up the chat real
quick and just find Joe for live yet
that's one your channel oh yeah yeah
we're live alright alright
guys I get to see the comments welcome
to Peter sage verse coffee Zilla
will bleach cure to the coronavirus the
whole is it out of context was it all a
lie
let's find out Peter sage I feel like
it's only fair that we give the floor to
you to start out did I get you out of
context what happened you said okay
let's put a little bit of information
around this that I think will help other
people understand it a little more right
I mean if you look at the original
opening lines that I had on that webinar
yeah it was this and I'll quote so I've
got the transcripts in front of me yeah
part of what I was pre framing this
entire content with was I am not
actually going to ask you to believe a
word I say I want you to do your own
research as one of my mentors often says
if it's not your experience it's not
your truth so I am NOT here to impose my
truth on you
I'm here to essentially say do your own
research that was the first thing I
opened up with now at no point during
that entire webinar on it was over two
hours and eight minutes of total content
I spent just shy of two minutes talking
about MMS in reaction to somebody's
question it was never meant to be in
there it was never part of my agenda to
bring forward and it wasn't in the
contents but nowhere let me stop right
there because that's simply not true you
may be MMS four times in that live
stream four times not like one time
offhanded four different times and some
of the times you brought it up yourself
you go I'm talking about the concept all
right so the actual concept at the end
of the webinar say okay let's go into
the Q&A I've done my way with you
hour-long it was half of the live stream
and which I'm sure everybody's question
mess up four times and in a debate which
is called in a webinar which is called
eliminate fear and protect yourself and
your family from the coronavirus you say
the number one thing I would reach out
reach for is MMS the number one thing so
correct you do mention and I meant I
mention it so this is in context I say
you promoted vitamin C iodine vitamin d3
all these things and I say yes he said
that so that's in context I took you in
context then I said correct didn't
someone asked you a question you said
hey I wasn't gonna bring that up I
mentioned that in the video and by the
way I made like a little side like sure
whatever because then you mention it
four different times and four different
times you say hey this is the number-one
thing if I got the coronavirus this
would kill the coronavirus in 48 hours
do you take that back or do you stand by
it
I'll read you the transcript I said it's
the number one go-to for me if I'm
looking at infections advanced cases of
viruses MMS you know cure any kind of
corona base virus in 48 hours using an
MMS protocol that was the words out of
my mouth
writing a webinar called eliminate fear
and protect yourself and family from
corona virus now whether or not you want
to see yourself as projecting as an
expert whether or not you want to say
hey I technically said you just do your
own research when you tell people when
you tell an audience look I'm this
health guy you say you're not a doctor
but you say you studied health I'm this
health guy and then you say the number
one I think I would reach forth the
expert is MMS a bleaching agent what do
you think that does the people what do
you think people are gonna take we
couldn't you can't have you kind of both
sides of the cherry if they respect me
and respect my view then the first thing
that I say is do your own research I'm
not here to ask you to believe a word I
say so if they respect my view that's
the first thing they're gonna say I'm
sorry I I don't I I don't think it's
that's a responsible way to look at your
audience is to say hey guys don't
believe anything I say so then you can
spout off and nothing matters no I don't
say that I said powerful cure for the
corona virus it will eliminate the
corona virus in 48 hours with zero
evidence is irresponsible and dangerous
I think that's completely untrue I think
that people that don't understand what I
was saying or don't have the concepts
are too lazy to have done their own
research
you say or did you not say that mms will
eliminate any Corona based virus in 48
hours yes correct I was actually a
little bit out of that yeah it'll kill
it on contacts in 300 milliseconds that
has nothing to do with whether someone
has the corona virus and they ingest
chlorine dioxide whether that will cure
him cure cure them
it's a disinfectant if I drink Purell
it's not gonna cure not the corona virus
even though it will kill the corona
viruses contact completely again
completely out of context this guy is
trying to tell you to go drink bleach
are you kidding me bleach is in tap
water
have you ever recommended somebody drink
tap water did you ask me what the
protocol was did you ask me what kind of
limits that were now again let me cut
let me let me quote you exactly from
what I said alright cuz here's the
transcript right mms aka chlorine
dioxide if it's used correctly words out
of my mouth can kill all viruses what
does it say about what is the FDA say
about mms do they say there's a correct
use is there a correct use is there a
proven correct use for mms which is
proven to cure the corona virus in 48
hours which is why you should do your
own research which is what your clients
are saying these things like if you just
say and then add a little disclaimer at
the end oh you guys really shouldn't
believe me anyways that's what I wasn't
a disclaimer at the a sponsible that's
what I opened up with now and hey listen
Steven if people took my ignored my
opening remarks that I kept going back
to I'm not gonna ask you to believe a
word I say do your own research again
that's just a way to absolve yourself of
any responsibility notice you say that
is a way to remember I can never be held
accountable for what I say cuz I tell my
audience to do their own research no
that's a way to empower people to stop
believing what everybody else tells them
oh come on dude telling people to do
their own research I don't have a
problem with that but then using that as
a way to absolve yourself of what you
claim the health claims you make
my man when you run a webinar called
eliminate fear and protect yourself from
coronavirus people are quite a figure I
signed up to that and I gave all of that
content for one hour that had nothing to
do with MMS right I was bored at all any
response no it's not the next hour was
all about MMS listen to yourself right I
spent less than two minutes out of that
next hour and eight minutes talking
about it I mention it for different
times less than two minutes come on dude
come on come on
are you a dollar store the way are you
gonna upload that that to YouTube no the
QA because again my it'll be taken out
of context what I did upload I put you
haven't explained how I how I took you
out of context I put you very much in
context I said what you initially
promoted then I said you mentioned MMS
and then I had you qualify what what did
how do I take you out of context the
information that I gave was solid sound
and just designed to help a huge amount
of people right well let me finish right
I wonder in that webinar all of the
stuff and we're gonna get into some of
that as you mentioned earlier sound did
you say sound sound advice yeah MMS as a
no I'm not talking about MMS that was in
the webinar that was in the webinar what
are you talkin to q and I am it wasn't
the content that I created that I put
out I was responding to somebody's
question God give me a break alright on
what I said was this it is my go to what
do you want to do lie I think you
shouldn't promote health claim I was not
intending to hello which is why you've
never seen me mention MMS in any other
public forum and it was a small amount
of people on a webinar that somebody
asked me and I gave my interpreter my
views about that claim you disavow the
claim that MMS don't care any Corona
based virus in 48 hours because it is
ridiculous and it isn't saying it is
dangerous
why do you disagree with that fact what
research have you done there's no
clinical trials there's not there's zero
evidence there's zero I disagree and I
just so happens I'll put it all up on
the website so you can have a look at it
but let me let me run through a couple
of
couple of things in sure cuz yeah this
might be useful for you okay and again
this is from the National Center for
Biotechnology and information advances
science and Health's government website
alright this is on PubMed yeah go go
check out but where is it I'm sorry do
you send me the link I want to look so
yeah go to Peter sage Co
oh no now you've got me go to your
website okay go go ahead go ahead
oh it's forward slash coffees overseas
Peter say Peter see these help Seiko
forward slash coffee zealous I'll talk
you through some of them these are all
off PubMed yeah peer review journals so
the first one study on the resistance of
severe acute receipt coronavirus using
chlorine dioxide yeah ensures complete
inactivation there's another one
controlled clinical evaluations of
chlorine dioxide in man in terms of oral
ingestion to assess the relative safety
of chronically administer chlorine water
disinfectants in man controlled studies
were undertaken in the absence of
detrimental psychological responses
within the limits of the study of the
relative safety of oral ingestion of
chlorine dioxide and its metabolites was
demonstrated going on own with first of
all thank you for I wish you would have
sent this to me before
but this doesn't show anything all this
shows look if your argument is that
using small quantities of chlorine
dioxide will not absolutely kill you
that's not what I'm arguing that's not
what I'm it says dude hold on one second
what I'm saying is there is zero
evidence of it curing the corona based
virus that's insane
and irresponsible where does it have
anything to do with the corona virus
especially kovat 19 by the way okay so
we're nowhere let's jump over to you
know how do you know you've not even
read the study
dude I'm looking at what you just read
me I'm just looking at what you just
read me hey let me share this go ahead
right so this is a commercially
available
oral ingested chlorine dioxin product
called
which one the grand prize award which in
Hungary which is an annual prize of
water for outstanding the inner service
solutions for projects in response to
the most pressing issues of the planet
in the field of Environmental Protection
sustainable development design medicine
health preservation and development and
education this is an award-winning
product which is hyper pure chlorine
dioxide solution right quote this kills
all pathogens including bacteria fungi
protozoa and viruses and it does so
without harming you it has no known side
effects ok and it is fluorine dioxide
solution hold on it's already on the
market slow down ok because let's think
about this think of this does chlorine
dioxide is chlorine dioxide a
disinfectant yes so chlorine bleach
which you drinking tap water so what's
your point chlorine dioxide is a
antibacterial on surfaces you don't cure
the human body by disinfecting your
stomach lining and your throat trap ok
so now you're a medical professional
no I defer to the medical professionals
who say that chlorine dioxide is
dangerous who say that Jim Humble is a
quack and a crank because of north
communism because he thinks he's part of
the space Navy but how are we deferring
to this guy unbelievable you think that
the FDA Big Pharma oh they're crazy
don't believe him they're out out to
lunch go do your own research you can't
trust those guys but Oh trust the space
Navy guy no I didn't say trust the space
Navy guy I didn't say you said oh you
said go read his book check out it yes
that's exactly what I said because in
his book in his book there's some useful
chemistry I just say follow Jim Hubble
look at the transcript I said go reduce
well we can look at the transcript
because you won't release the video
release the video and they never can
look at it come on training so hard
elicit and you say to look at the
transcript as if that proves your point
I will concede that I will which is why
I never had
and part in response to somebody else's
question which I was trying to help with
by giving my own version and my model
the four different times so it wasn't
one direction it wasn't one question
enough for it they mentioned it in the
chat more than four times it was
mentioned in the chat more than four
times that's what I was responding to
right okay it was never on my radar
somebody else brought that on but it is
the number one thing you'd take if you
got the crowd a virus for me personally
yes that was what I said no but you also
said it will cure any corona base virus
which is not like a personal all just
for me that's like a health claim and
which I've used about several times and
you will not disavow it okay then credit
given right
I will retract any public recommendation
of MMS which I've never made I made it
on a private webinar you did make it
don't say you didn't make it you made it
and you're retracting it that's fine
I'll retracts it I've got no program I
don't want people going out there and
again here's here's the transcript I
mean let me just read exact I was so
careful about what I was saying alright
and these are my actual words if it's
used correctly it's a form of bleach if
you have it in the wrong doses it will
screw you up you have to be very careful
with it it's powerful stuff
just like any I was so keen to better
get that message across because I don't
want people neither does the FDA running
out trying to admit itself administer
chlorine dioxide from sources that may
have contaminants but for me personally
my own personal goes through having
looked at all of the research that I'm
happy with
yes that was my personal preference
that's what I was saying look look and
let me extend a little olive branch to
you first of all I'm happy you retracted
that second of all let me say this I
have no problem with what you do in your
spare time but we're in the middle of a
global pandemic the likes of which we've
never seen maybe since the Spanish flu
okay agreed what a disaster to be
recommending anything like chlorine
dioxide and claiming it's a cure so that
people don't listen to their doctor like
the whole thing is that you're saying oh
the doctors pharma doesn't know what
they're talking about they do know what
their
okay that's the message you need to be
putting out there now whether or not you
want or no message at all but whether or
not you want to take chlorine dioxide in
your free time dose however much you
want I don't care but this is super
irresponsible and that was what my whole
video was about in context so you'd say
two hours and eight minutes of what was
predominantly excellent information
designed to calm people down
which I'm very happy to get into that
side designer can't be able down add a
huge amount of value to people give them
away terms of product premium products
thousands of pounds of product which I
thought my helpers should be able to
calm the fair without even asking for an
email address I gotta jump in here I
gotta jump in here I'm sorry because you
just said excellent sound advice in that
webinar because we haven't gotten into
the rest of the webinar and we
definitely are because you did say a lot
of other things in that webinar and a
lot of it was equally crazy I won't say
equally harmful but equally crazy you
guys because you say that Louis
Pasteur's germ theory doesn't exist I
guess we're gonna go back to miasma the
theory of bad air bad rotting air
everywhere so you say germs theory
doesn't exist I guess germs don't exist
you said I said germ theory was just
proven in 1914 that was my actual quote
Jesus all right hold on let me get to go
through these so well we'll talk about
them in due course Joe and then you also
say that I what sorry I don't have the
transcript in front of me because you
won't release it but you talked about
not believing in vaccines or saying that
vaccines no I said I wouldn't take them
back saying Yeah right because have you
looked at what's in those vaccines
that's what you said all right yeah
would you consider yourself an
anti-vaxxer yes I know my own advice are
you insane your being there isn't a
vaccine for Kobe 19 right now and right
now all I've got is what you said you
said you said the human body's the
immune system and if they gave me a
Kovan 19 vaccine i wouldn't take it
correct come
sitting yourself at my own writing yet
you're running yourself as a webinar
about how to protect yourself and you're
telling people oh me personally I
wouldn't take the quarter virus vaccine
and I've ever tried to be able to say
that it's just dangerous and
irresponsible my mam it's whatever you
point of view save alright
watch me real quick explain this to me
real quick huh
okay so you believe that Big Pharma's
out for money and because they're out
for money they would never cure a
disease when they can make them a profit
from the management of the disease right
Big Pharma is currently responsible for
the third leading cause of death in
America hold on answer my question real
quick we'll get into that in a second
cuz I want to talk about your little
claim there sure but do you believe that
big farmers trying to profit off people
by managing the disease rather than
curing it
if you look historically I think that
wouldn't be a false claim to entertain
okay then what's a vaccine if not the
cure for a disease to cure for a disease
yeah vaccines are a cure for a disease
disease people always say oh yeah
they're hiding the cure for this hiding
the cure for that and then those same
people tell you to not go get a vaccine
what insanity what sanity I'm saying I
wouldn't have some largely untested
substance injected into my body that's
what I'm saying no you also said your
anti backs which is just a general thing
to be correct do it know that what sees
a general thing for me to be no for
anyone else I was stating what my
personal preferences which I'm
absolutely entitled to case closed oh my
gosh you're promoting it on a live
stream that's about how to prevent and
protect yourself from coronavirus dude
that wasn't a short often comment in the
questions and answers I didn't lead with
that I lived with four major parts of
the information no some sound advice
some of your sounded it's long it's on
my youtube channel go check it some of
your sound advice is anti backs and then
hold on let's go for this other one
which is you believe that germ theory
doesn't exist no I said it was just
proven in 1914 what do you what
what do you think Jim theory is let's
establish that germ theory is the idea
that germs are the cause of disease so
previously there was this idea of miasma
which is the idea that if you had if you
were diseased if you were in a diseased
state you would attract the disease you
would attract the thing that caused the
disease right this was previously the
model of the world then Louis Pasteur
came along and said hey actually there
are these things called germs and if you
get a specific germ you get a specific
disease to that germ and it was proven
as far as theories can be proven just
like we have the theory of gravity it
still called a theory but we've proven
it time and time again with things like
Robert Koch demonstrating with the
anthrax bacteria he demonstrated that
this one bacteria caused this one
disease right we've proven time and time
again the foundations of modern medicine
are on germ theory that is not what I
was stating and how you just represented
that was not what I was explaining again
that those slides are on my youtube
channel go check it out right so what I
was actually explaining was the germs
are not responsible for the actual
disease of the brain inside the body is
responsible well how can you have one
person in a household that has the germ
and not everybody in the house will get
the disease it doesn't make sense in the
germ theory germ theory means exposure
equals disease and it doesn't is the
terrain if you have a healthy immune
system let me slow you down real quick
okay
because germ theory doesn't totally
ignore a healthy immune system versus a
compromised immune system that would be
insane okay if user theory thought that
exposure exposure to a disease is how
you get the disease contingent on how
your immune system reacts to it just
because you are exposed to a virus does
not mean that you will necessarily get
the virus in in the way of being
symptomatic but and if the experiments
are proven that if you have a healthy
terrain those germs will actually mutate
into harmless organisms
I mean you're like you're citing
crackpots stop dude you're citing
bootcamp look hey uh I'm Bhushan was a
crackpot is that what you're saying yes
no no I what no you said that Louis
Pasteur admitted that Louis that boot
camp was right is that right you said
that in the livestream
why do you call it correct okay are you
are you aware of that that's a total
myth
so you quoted it you quoted in your live
stream saying there was this big fight
between Louis Pasteur who believed in
germ theory and Duchamp right and and on
his deathbed you said Louis Pasteur said
hey actually it just so happens that
boot camp was right I was wrong that
terrain is everything there's a widely
quoted all alternative medicine thing
that is a total myth so this guy and
I'll have to link it I should have
created my own thing on my youtube
channel coffee Zilla calm for it's like
oh that'll be cool Peter sage but but
that web site doesn't exist guys but
I'll have to link it in the in the show
notes here let me see if I can get it
real quick we have an arms race on
competing links yeah link it in chat for
everybody so that never happened just to
be clear just to be totally clear in
fact instead actually how he died was
somebody said hey he was like frail and
somebody said hey would you like a cup
of milk and he said I can't and he died
which makes sense people when they're
dying don't utter profound things they
say like they like mumble like the small
things the guy's not gonna go oh yeah I
recant my life's work and admit this guy
that I thought was crazy was actually
totally right okay and the actual
reality is nobody was actually there to
be able to prove it in today so you
could make up to wake up his son relate
the biography oh really so so so germs
cause disease and therefore if everybody
has the germ everybody's gonna get the
disease that was the
no no that's not what anyone's saying
germ theory is that germs will be the
cause of disease and it's contingent on
your immune system as well but the point
is the point is I agree with the point
is fully agree with not get coronavirus
without being exposed to the coronavirus
it's correct
that's germ theory then you agree with
germ theory I agree with that premise
what I didn't agree with was how most
people see germ theory is that exposure
to the disease equals disease and it
doesn't I don't I don't think I know
anyone who believes that though well
anyone whose families had a germ that
you haven't got sick from no no I'm
saying I don't know anyone who believes
in that representation of what germ
theory is what the germs you get you a
guarantee to get yeah nobody disease if
you get expect to the German yeah nobody
believes that because everybody knows
you can get you can you can be near
somebody you can get some virus and you
can be asymptomatic you have it in your
your your body but you're asymptomatic
and your body fights it out before you
get any disease everyone knows that I
was essentially what I was saying in the
webinar no you were saying Louis Pasteur
is wrong and that and Louie Pastore
basically proved that germs cause
disease and you're saying that's not
true which is one of the foundations
also of the reason people don't believe
in vaccines they go well how can this be
when actually we just need to keep the
body like keep the body the Terrain good
and so why should we be worried about
disease so one follows the other when
you're promoting this like crackpot
Terrain theory thing you're also almost
simultaneously promoting anti packs as
well that's a interesting conclusion but
I that's what you believe as well so I
don't know my personal preference is I
won't say Kovak Singh I know and again I
don't have a problem with your personal
preference what I stated in the video
what I stated in the video is that I
think what you're saying on this webinar
where you're pushing yourself as
eliminate fear and protect yourself and
family I feel like a broken record I
feel like it's dangerous and your
response
for you giving to be given this medical
device and it's robbing the air from
doctors who are trying to give
common-sense stuff because they are not
promising cures because they can't
because they're responsible and they're
not going to promise cures did something
they don't have a cure for you are
you're saying there's cures you're
saying MMS I said exactly what I said
acted would you retract it but what I'm
saying is that's what I said I said it
was dangerous and irresponsible and I
don't know which part of that you
disagree with because you retracted it
so I mean in some ways that's most of
what I had a problem with if it's used
correctly it can kill a viruses and I
was taking that from the science that
I've just put up on there which feel
free to read through all the studies as
to why it's safe for humans to take in
the right doses unless my own personal
problems there's no clinical trial of
chlorine dioxide being proven to cure
any virus I think but I don't have a
look at what
well someone doesn't exist that doesn't
exist you said it's the most powerful
malaria cure no it's not that's absolute
insanity there's not a study that says
that and it's again robbing the air from
people on the front lines doing the work
and promoting some space Navy guy and
getting him ripped and one of the things
I will agree with people should not go
out and believe the [ __ ] claims that
have been hijacked
just like you exposing other false gurus
that make false claims about trying to
say take this get rich if you are using
MMS which is an exceptionally powerful
Eliminator of pathogens viruses toxis
parasites etc it's a disinfectant all
right so is chlorine in hot water no I'm
saying like if you put it on a surface
it's it's more like Lysol or something
like that
as far as you slugs why'd you showed it
won a national award for being able to
be orally administer to kill viruses
it's that's called fact no it's not no
it's not oh it's not a fact that
selenium didn't win an award for
Aurel administered hi I have no way look
I have I don't have the chance to look
at that right now but what I'm saying is
that has it been through a clinical
trial well clearly no it hasn't come on
- oh so okay fair enough good I'll be
happy for you to make a retraction when
you go and have a look at that and come
back okay that it kills all viruses in
the in the body right that's what you
said it cures all viruses in the body
that's absolutely not true it's insane
again it's like drinking Purell it
really is like taking that a low-dose
Purell so it wouldn't kill you it might
hurt your stomach but and then telling
people oh yeah you know how pure OQ
cleans your hands
we'll try drinking it why not that's
crazy and you're responsible and don't
have no clinical trials to back it up do
your own research okay I say I'm not
here to impose my truth on you let's
let's talk about some of that research
okay because we have a do you know who
II know Frey is no all right he's the
guy who wrote the article about how
chlorine dioxide cures malaria it's it's
one of the only studies out there I was
looking for studies to support your
argument okay so I was I was saying okay
let me try to engage with this and you
know I don't want to take out of context
again so this seems to be the only study
that I could find on chlorine dioxide
treating treating it okay so let me link
this in chat and let me tell you what I
found because it was quite actually not
that surprising okay first of all the
study was retracted after it was found
that the people did not use any control
group for their study they didn't tell
the people that they were being given
chlorine dioxide and guess what they
gave alongside chlorine dioxide in the
study an anti-malarial drug a pill yes
and then they said hey chlorine dioxide
cures malaria maybe it was the anti
malarial pill you gave with the chlorine
dioxide and for the lack of the control
group you have no choice but to conclude
that Wow is it clear
like such a great anti malarial agent no
you gave an anti-malarial drug like it
so that study should be retracted and I
wasn't quoting that or referencing it no
no what I'm saying is that's the that's
the only evidence that I'm aware of
look check it out and then the guy the
guy said he was gonna release results
and he didn't release results I mean
this is the kind of support for your
argument that you have is these people
who are not doing things properly and
you mentioned in the livestream that
like chlorine dioxide has been vilified
it's been you know it's been cracked
down upon maybe this is why because
people are doing unethical human
experimentation without prior notice to
those humans they're not control group
they're they're hacking the study so
that they can come to a predetermined
conclusion right so I mean what are you
talking about and then you're gonna say
in a live stream that it's the most ant
powerful cure for malaria you'll ever
see and that is from the transcript by
the way that's not true that's not a
claim you can make there's no study to
support it I wasn't setting out to make
medical claims and so if I made a
medical claim full apologies full
retraction okay all right well yeah that
wasn't that was not going away
has not been proven to cure anything
period luckily people now can do their
own research on those articles and those
studies and you can go and have a look
at selenium and come back and tell me
what you think because there is evidence
out there I was I'm reliable I would say
this guys defer to your health
authorities when the FDA says there's no
reason to be drinking chlorine dioxide
because it's a poison defer to them
right I I would say that when they'll
say dropping across the countries when
health officials across the country are
saying don't drink mms the I would say
defer to them wouldn't you say that the
World Health Organization specifically
states that the use of chlorine dioxide
to purify water of bacteria viruses etc
is a protocol so when they're given
a lot of your governments are using
chlorine dioxide in water instead of
your existing remember very rare to
purify an extraordinarily low doses
right correct
I didn't give a high dose recommend to
purify water not to purify the body not
to cure an illness but if you're in some
country with unpalatable water you have
no choice chlorine dioxide
yeah it'll purify water Oh fantastic so
if you've got but not the first but but
again but again not in doses like Jim
Humble is recommending we're on his
website he states that using the
protocol normally he says the MMS
protocol 1000 normally he says hey guys
you might experience some nausea
diarrhea and vomiting and if you do slow
it down a little bit okay those are way
past the concentrations that anybody's
recommending for purifying water which
concentrations are they specifically oh
my gosh now I'm just saying if you've
done the research or if you're just
sparing and I'm citing you what's on Jim
humbles own website
I mean that's on that's on the guy who
created the space Navy pirate who
created an MMS is saying he'd found hey
guys Nadja diarrhea and vomiting yeah if
that's eggs in large doses which is why
when you take the MMS 1000 protocol
which by the way is very specific I said
go look on the protocols know if it's
used correctly it can kill all viruses
if you get it wrong it'll screw you up
you have to be very careful with it it's
out of my mouth you said if you talked
about it four times so you one of the
times you said if I got the virus
I'd be start taking the ms1000 protocol
that's the protocol you said you would
take I would correct that was what I
would take personally right the one that
Jim Humble says may and can cause nausea
diarrhea and vomiting when taken in its
normal course like not if you are a
demon have you ever read the side
effects of any drug yeah yeah the ones
that have been proven to cure stuff
you've been the ones that have gone
through clinical trials with control
groups yeah
the ones that kill the third leading
cause of death of everybody in the
United States case closed
what are you talking about my bad
correctly prescribed pharmaceutical
drugs is the third leading cause of
death in the u.s. not true according to
Harvard University's Ethics Control
Committee I think you're mistaken many
many others I think you're mistaken
well again go have a look okay if you
should wake up late correctly prescribed
pharmaceuticals drugs it's all the web
so Kay okay okay already ellipsis that
because I knew you're gonna make this
claim okay already look today this is
absolutely not true of course is not
true because you speaking of taking
things out of context like come on man
the actual fact behind that is that
accidents medical accidents are the
leading cause of death and so that is
when something goes wrong in our medical
system that is the cause of death
that's not prescribed drugs okay let's
be clear that's when a surgery goes
wrong because every surgery carries risk
yes it is a percentage or it should be
days medical listen third leading cause
of death if anyone looks it up right now
they will find the title of it is
medical mistakes or accidents that is
not correctly prescribed drugs that's an
absolute lie go keep looking further
there's been more than a greater one
study by John Hopkins more than 250,000
people died in the United States every
year because of medical state medical
mistakes making it the third leading
cause of death after heart disease in
cancer which by the way you 2018 okay
so again you'll see various others
online that'll come up with various
different numbers but but really
describes you were again speaking of
taking out of context you're taking
medical errors to be prescribed drugs
and saying all drugs are bad no they're
not drugs save lives doctor save lives
nurses save lives and yes we have
mistakes to err is human but thank God
we have a meta notion that doesn't rely
on drinking bleach ah all I remember
right now where's my Purell yeah my
slope
people down alright no chlorine dioxide
as a water purifier and as a
decontaminant bearing in mind that a lot
of the coded 19 breathes within the
throats so if you gargle mms anything
that's in the throat as co bead 19 will
be killed I mean what are you talking
about good night reads in the throat
we're seeing that what do you what are
you talking about where's the study on
that it's in the airway
no no but you just said it breeds in the
throat I don't know what you're talking
about we're we're in the throat like
like in the mouth like in the air in the
lungs you mean what you can't gargle in
your lungs right mouth and airway right
but your airway is is your lungs you're
not gonna gargle hopefully you're not
gonna gargle MMS in your lungs not
correct okay so that's that's meaning
but if there is an e in the throat it
would die on contact if you were to
gobble chlorine dioxide that was my
people drink it though right
not gargle it okay and you could equally
suggest someone gargle Listerine that's
not gonna save you from the coronavirus
there's again no study to support that
no clinical trial to support that and
just again I hate routing off again
about like these really these random
facts that don't exist what I was doing
right from the start was telling
everybody what my personal preference
was which again I have every right to do
some people will deal with their issues
on alcohol some people deal with
meditation somebody do it with therapy
it doesn't matter whatever he's quite
rightly says Steven whatever your
personal preference are people are able
to go and do and all I was sharing is
what my personal preferences are having
prefaced it with don't believe a word I
say do your own research
again again we've been through this not
everything she said was personal advice
right which now you've retracted so
apparently you don't think it's okay and
within your rights to just be saying
anything anytime but uh but although if
I wrote it well I agree with your listen
listen I agree with your right to free
speech which is why I'm not I'm not I
don't want anyone to shut you down I
don't want anyone to stretch your
YouTube channel down I'm saying what
you're saying is
dangerous and irresponsible I wish you'd
stop and that's all I'm saying and I'm
saying there's no scientific evidence
and I'm on a live stream to prove it and
I think I've pretty definitively proved
it
but speaking of shutting down free
speech I've got to bring this up I hate
to bring this up on the call before like
five minutes before we started this
livestream you mentioned and I freaking
hate that you said this you mentioned
that your lawyers were thinking about
taking action on that video and right
before the livestream started is that
not true you said and then and then I
said by the fact that you might take
legal action against me for my video
when it seems like you're just coming on
to debate there's this undertone of oh I
might actually sue you will you say on
this debate on this debate on this live
call that you will not sue me for that
video no of course I can't say that dude
this is what I'm talking about this is
what fake gurus do bad they come on they
come on the show and they pretend to be
oh yeah I'm up for debate but actually
if you don't take your video down better
see you cops on my man so you want me to
give you free speech but you don't want
to give me free speech notice all I'm
saying that in the interest of
protecting the business this is what
upsets me about people like yourself
statement right because I thought of
respect for you coming on here right you
go into an industry which you and I have
a lot of similar thoughts on which is
yeah get to people I take this away from
you trying to sue me hold on hold on
don't talk this way from you try to see
where we'll all right I'm not trying to
see my lawyers are chomping at the bit
and we and they have every right soon
but I persuaded you in context you've
publicly retracted the things that you
said on that livestream because you said
yes they were dangerous and you're
responsible right and then now you're
saying now you're saying well actually
actually I'm actually thinking about
taking legal action against you Stephen
if you don't watch I don't know I'm not
I said my lawyers do you have control of
your lawyers don't pretend like those
are some autonomous thing so what
happens is your decision so you can
decide right now on this nice I did not
take legal action against me and you
should because that's respecting free
speech
and I'm not gonna make that decision say
what's going on here's how I said this
is this is my life guys this is my life
I want you to understand these fakers
they're chomping this and they it's not
this is this is ego man you're trying to
protect my ego come on I'm kidding me
dude right I put a one-hour webinar out
there with content that was devoid of
everything that you've been trying to
pin me on for all I know is two hours
you know CMMS four times you talked
about being anti backs in the comments
in relation to unsolicited questions at
the end after I'd given the information
that I set out to give give that some
frickin point right I talked and I said
what you initially recommended that's
what I said that's what I said I know
that it had boolean context and now you
want to sue me for presenting things
fully in context and then you pretend
like hey I'm happy to chat about it but
there's this weird veiled threat this
sword of Damocles over my head of like
hey I might be suing you next week by
the way did I mention on that one of the
things I mentioned on that content which
again you haven't even brought up yeah
in the interest of being everybody
responsible is what I talk about the app
it push yes away from you trying to sue
me I'm not trying to sue you
I simply mention the fact that my
lawyers have said that this is a
potential threat and I said let me go
speak with the guy
let me give my side of the story so
basically if this live stream doesn't
turn out the way you want and I don't
take down the video and what was the
last thing I said to you that is
definitely not a place I want to go it's
not a route I want to go now I don't
think so I'm in the bail truck what do
you mean it's not the place want to go
if it's a place you don't want to go you
don't have to go there if you go there
you wanted to go there let's be totally
clear about that no it's because you
wanted to shut down my speech because
you don't like when people present you
in full context and then when it's you
saying something that you shouldn't have
said let's just be honest you shouldn't
have said it you say you shouldn't have
said it and now you want to sue me to
take it off the internet and you want to
Peter not me not your lawyers you want
to cuz you're promoting me as a false
fury
when all of my work is not about health
I was trying to do the service to people
to show them why a lot of the statistics
that they're being fed are not the
statistical and give them a service meal
by promoting MMS know that is absolute
[ __ ] go check out go check out his
book go check out the protocols the
first thing I would do is in response to
people talking to me
excuse you Peter please you you're
writing a webinar about how to cure the
corona virus please tell me how you're
gonna cure the corona part oh guys just
take mms and you're not my personal
preference you're not promoting oh yeah
people ask me where I could buy it from
I said go to your own research just like
I said right at the beginning mm-hmm go
do it go do your own research
Yeah right yeah don't believe a word I
say all right what else you want me to
say how many other full stories or what
I want you to say is that you're not
gonna sue me because I don't want to be
part of a lawsuit you say allegedly you
don't want to be a part of a lawsuit so
let's not be let's just agree right now
that you're not gonna be I hate to say
it fragile about what's being said about
you you're happy to be criticized I
think everyone does okay totally up to
that okay great sorry no bonus all that
conclusion because that's a good-ass a
commercially different agenda okay I'm
telling you man you make a million
dollars you just become a guy who can't
who can't be criticized
I swear dude I say you're not open
you're not open to criticism
no come on the show I want to come on
the show and if the right thing doesn't
happen on the show right the right thing
doesn't happen this shows oh I'm gonna
spoil them all my options I might I
might see you I might see you I'm always
I'm always gonna keep my options open
dude come this is not a good look Peter
it's not a real look at all I said I'm
always gonna keep my options open that's
responsible dude when you're puck know
what I'm saying though is your publicly
saying yeah I believe in free speech
yeah man you have the right to criticize
me and then very clearly you don't
believe that very clearly you don't
that depends exactly on the listen I
will say right now I'm willing to
promise on this webinar that I will not
sue you okay I won't call you for a nice
of you
yeah well absolutely happy to help so I
can say that I can close my day option
on that cuz I know how I feel about free
speech and I know how I feel about
criticism stuff like that the right to
criticize if you're not willing to close
that door I don't think people can
believe you I mean I think people have
to confess in conclusion to draw from
that I'm gonna keep my options open
depending on what the advice is that I
get third pretty simple did you did you
touch on the fact that the test for the
co vid 19 doesn't actually test for
curve 19 did you only research on that
that was one of the things I'll shut up
that's one of the things I was trying to
calm people down with on the webinar
when I was trying out somebody I'm sorry
I can't get past the fact that you're
about to sue me I can't get past that
fact at all I was gonna this livestream
how it's going so far I think I'm gonna
expect to get de LOI from you a letter
from your lawyers I'm pretty sure by it
is that gonna happen or is it not just
tell us
you kind of know but the honest you kind
of know you kind of know right now is
that gonna happen not gonna commit but
it's a possibility the public record I'm
so happy because everybody like I always
say that this happens behind the scenes
I'm always telling people about this but
people don't actually I'm not sure they
really they don't have like you know
it's just better to see in person so I'm
happy people were able to see this
happen on a live stream somebody
basically break down and go yeah if
things don't roll my way I'm gonna use
my money to silence you because that's
exactly what you're saying make no
mistake about it you want to silence
people with your wealth from selling
5,000 okay Shane right and you want to
show show right you want to sell it to
an independent journalist like me who's
covering the issues
who says who you say you agree with you
say hey man I'm a supporter of you oh
yeah real supporter real I like some of
the stuff that you do I like some of the
stuff that you do because the whole
context of personal growth has a lot of
charlatans and try to get money off
people and you know those charlatans I'm
not deliver you know that Charlotte
they're trying to get money all the
people you know how charlatans hide
they hide by suing people and silencing
people from giving their actual beliefs
and so they maintain this perfect
reputation online right now yes they do
oh yes they don't pretend that the only
way that you can use lawyers that's the
playbook that's the playbook of people
who decide they want to sue you if they
want to sue people into silence so they
seem like these beautiful here's the
thing right you said you've been
following me for a while all right you
sign up to your email list you said
you've been following me for a while
right you said you had your eye on this
guy for a while that's what you actually
put in you sure yeah yeah right and so
having go to all of my work all my
videos any any of the information you've
come across the only thing you can pick
me up on is the response to some
unsolicited questions at the end of a
frickin webinar they make a mess and by
saying for an hour I wasn't planning for
now you Muppet and that's most of what
you talk again again I would really love
I would love Oh and you talked about how
germ theory is a big hoax - right like
how Louis Pasteur that's that's a big
hole that's all online go check it out
so I use your China
that's not go I hope took the life from
you today hey listen here's my request
for you Peter
here's my request for you Peter go put
go put it up go probable soon here I'll
put the transcript I'm happy to put the
transcript up right I'll send you the
transcripts put the vid I'll make it
about how much they wouldn't say but I'm
quoting right it wasn't a subject I was
gonna bring up clearly if used correctly
dude all right no basis right with Apple
you have to know the trials no medical
basis but you feel like that's
responsible too and you haven't read any
of the things that I've put up well
going through all of those studies you
just put them up you want me to see here
for an hour to read them no but you're
quite willing to sit there and then just
dismiss everything and say there is no
clinical trials because
what you but because what you read to me
was only saying that hey this is a
disinfectant that in low doses can be
taken orally with little side effect but
not in mms doses by the way it wasn't in
the mms dose which Jim Humble admits
will cause nausea vomiting diarrhea
again far less than any side effects of
any prescription drug if you read any
live into one again we're running in
circles improvement we're running in
circles and what and I'm just trying to
get to the facts okay I'm trying to get
that so here's my version of the facts
statement right you're gonna sue me
is what I'm worried about yeah
[Applause]
conclusion no how are you gonna save a
live stream when I'm trying to be
cordial I'm trying to debate you but I'm
also trying to give your side of the I
guess he looked up your malaria your
malaria articles I tried to look up
evidence of my malaria articles no
that's the only article available my
point is I'm trying to give you the
benefit without my information that came
from that was from the people why did
you on my show because I want to give
you the right to speak and you're
telling me oh yeah I'm probably gonna
sue you are you nuts
here's my main point I spend huge amount
of time and effort putting together
something that I wanted to help people
with that had nothing to do with mms and
I didn't say all you promote it was a
mess though right no I don't I don't
promote anything health what I promote
yeah is having the right mindset to be
able to deal with this environment all
right being able to have enough of self
empowerment to be able to make your own
decisions alright something I've always
quoted and every part every person
that's looked at any of my videos just
looked at any of read my books has
always been empowered as a result of
that I'm not one of these people that's
got a huge refund line I'm not on these
people online they get yeah it's like
that and you take one tiny little piece
of all of the work that I do and say do
not trust this man alright denying all
of the people that could he get fowling
dude what are you talking about man I
never said don't trust this man
I said you said that light is dangerous
and irresponsible which it is in that
was advice and you've retracted it no
come on do we been over this you
retracted it because you were saying
yeah if there was just I retract it
don't backtrack on it just want to go 30
now you've retracted it great let's move
on you've retracted it that's fine my
own personal preference we need you in
context I said this stuff in particular
is crazy did I ever say hey Peter sage
himself he cannot be trusted nothing he
says can be trusted no I said his advice
on this is garbage which by the way if I
ever promoted MMS and somebody said hey
your advice on this is garbage I'd be
I'd hope I'd be open to the evidence
that it absolutely was true and I
wouldn't be jumping to sue them because
I had the money to do it so I you may
have a team of lawyers I don't have a
team of lawyers on deck buddy
I mean like you're trying to bully me
with your money that's what you're doing
you're a bully just like all these other
gurus you're you're a millionaire bully
you're trying to bully people into
silence and to stop criticizing you stop
criticizing protects your reputation
that is preventing people from getting
the benefit of what I'm really about no
no that's not a reason to sue so you can
sue somebody because they've slandered
or they've libeled you which I quote
neither of you call me a false guru okay
first of all first of all first of all
first of all fake guru is not a factual
thing it's an opinion it's an opinion
it's my opinion in which we share right
you can't sue companion Peter you assume
other people you sue people because they
made a false factual claim about you
which by the way you haven't said I made
made about you so what are you talking
about you want to sue me because you
know legal costs are expensive right you
know that I'm not gonna want to go
through a long protracted legal battle
and you're gonna want to shut me up
without actually having a real case you
don't have a real case here you want to
gin up some bogus reason to sue me so
that you can get the video taken down
this should be honest about what it is
you don't have a case you just want to
cost me money because you know you have
more money than me because you sell a
$5,000 course and I do not
and you're preventing a lot of people
that I could help from making an
assumption about Who I am and what I
stand for and what I do and I gave you
this platform to clear that up and
you've done a tremendous job of clearing
that up
yeah of explaining right from the start
that you're gonna start reframe not bad
about you everything that don't believe
a word I say
do your own research yeah I'm not here
to impose my truth on you Claude I said
if it's used correctly I can help if
it's not used correctly it can screw you
up
what yeah what out of all of that is not
advice that yeah you would shift in a
different way like for you I want to I
wanted to give you the last word I think
we're running I feel like we're running
in circles and I don't want to run in
circles I migrated back the viewer's
time but I think people can as I said in
our email exchange I want people to draw
their own conclusions from our
back-and-forth I hope they do get an
idea of more of what you're about and do
you have any last thoughts for us do
your own research I've put some
information up and people can judge
their own conclusions and again I'm not
here to try to make anybody in from
influence anybody do anything that yeah
there are over 21 they should be able to
make their own decisions you're not
trying to influence anyone unless
they're criticizing you then you want to
influence them alright guys thank you so
much for watching appreciate it fun
should be interesting
alright hey thanks for the super chats
guys